the web forward
and my um what i want to encourage
everyone to do
is to open up your favorite projects on
github or wherever they're at
and get pull requests and issues ready
because i'll be discussing
common uh performance oversights
in popular libraries and possibly in
your own code so
if you find something that's useful
tweet it there's hashtag perforward
and at the end of the talk i'd like to
see like a list of hands of how many or
show off hands to see
how many issues have been reported or
pull requests have been
started so cool
all right a little bit about me uh i'm
co-maintainer of jsperf.com
how many people have used jsperf.com
awesome cool
uh wow uh i'm also the lead dev on
lowdash so lowdash is an underscore
alternative how many people have heard
of the
dash awesome sweet and then benchmark.js
and benchmark js is what powers jsperf
and it also allows you to do things
on node ringo rhino
all the browsers and then i'm also a
perf pm at microsoft so i help make
chakra the javascript engine faster
all right i'm back kind of
cool and um by by looking at patterns
popular patterns on the web and um
helping relay them to the c
plus java engine devs
and i am a javascript fanboy so
before i begin and talk about the
specific performance tweaks
um there's a couple of themes that i'll
be trying to reiterate throughout the
talk
and that's optimized for the common case
optimized for the common case
whenever you're implementing a api
design or
or using a library if you are a library
author
think about the most common case for
that api to be used and
and optimize for it everything else is
secondary at that point um
a lot of mistakes i've seen when uh devs
are doing apis is they they're they're
they're putting things in their
code that slow things down for no
for no reason or for this edge case uh
the scenario
next is is using natives wisely last
year i gave a talk
at jsconf called the hidden cost of
natives
and that was looking at the performance
of
native methods like array for each
filter map and then comparing them to
alternatives
written with for loops also things like
bind as well
and then avoid abstraction one of the
easiest ways to gain performance
in a javascript library or a javascript
project is to just peel back
a layer of abstraction reduce those
function calls
you don't have to go crazy you don't
have to
compile all the things like method
compilation
but just pulling back a layer of
abstraction can help you with your perf
and then the balance the pros and the
cons everything i'm talking about here
is is just advice if you're not seeing a
performance issue then you certainly
don't have to refactor your code and run
out and do it
i work with a lot of like low level
library
functions where they have to be fast
because you don't know what's going to
be built on top of it it's the baseline
for a lot of projects and so
keep that in mind when i show like i'll
show one way to implement something and
then i'll show
another way to implement it that gets a
little bit deeper and then you know
code and kind of increases and
complexity increases so you just have to
judge for yourself
like do i want to pre-compile all things
or do i just want to maybe just remove
one layer of abstraction
so cool now that that's out of the way
all right so i also hope to blow some
minds and i just love this gif so
there's that let's just
let's just absorb this for a second how
awesome
it repeats forever too i love it okay
okay so the the first technique is
uh to hoist out dot call and dot apply
from your iteration functions um and
then i put a little key down here
at the bottom that shows the libraries
that this applies to so if you use any
of these libraries this technique
applies to that and you can create a
patch for it or an issue
for that library so that's backbone dojo
amber jquery prime which is mootools2
and then underscore and i'm sure there's
more every every library has some kind
of iteration utility
every library has some kind of event
loop or event emitter
and this technique can be applied to
those so the the general gist is we've
all seen code like this while loop
callback.call and what it's doing is
it's doing the dot call
for the this this arg you're this
context but if you don't pass it this
context
it's still or this arg it's still doing
a dot call and that is slower than
just a straight function call so one way
to do it like we all know like when you
have
loops you move the the hard work out of
the loop
and in this case you can move that dot
call out of the loop
by doing something like this
so this create callback allows you to
evaluate and do the binding inside this
function here
and then in your main loop you've just
got
a straight function call and so that
increases your
uh your iteration performance and your
events emitter performance
and the inside of that function there
that i've highlighted looks like this
aha there it is like this um
if you don't pass it this arc it just
returns the callback and if you do
it wraps the function and does the dot
call now this makes your common case
very very fast and i'll show you i'll
step back
this is i applied this optimization to
backbone which already has a very fast
event system like they go out of their
way to really
fine tune it and you're still able to
get
performance gains in various browsers
because of this
and i'll step back or forward
there's trade-offs for this this makes
your common case very fast this makes
your case where you pass this arg very
slow um
because it is having to do a function
wrapper so there's there's variations
you can do on this
um what you can do is you can check to
see if
there uh is it this i'll show you here
if there is a this binding and then um
in your loop do a conditional sure like
a ternary operator that says hey if
there's a binding
do the call if not or do the the
function call with.call if not then
do.call
and that will give you a little bit
better performance and not as bad
a big of a perf penalty so it's just up
to you to weigh the pros and cons of
your approach
one of the good things about using
create callback
is that with this approach you could
then add extra functionality
without having to modify this function
you could just modify
create callback so i did this with
lodash
for our map function usually there's a
function called pluck which would then
you you give it a collection
or an array of objects let's say and you
want to get the the name
property value off of all the objects
there's a function called pluck which
would do that well instead you could
have
map which we all know what array map is
you could have map that accepts
a string a string for callback and
it would pass here and it would
automatically create the callback that
does
the object property retrieval for you
and it's at zero perf cost so you're
able to extend
your your existing iteration function
without
any extra perf cost and it's optimized
for the common case
so you get win win win win out of that
all right before i get into the next one
i also want to touch on
event systems like jquery so if we
looked at back at this
chart here you saw that so this is
higher is better so
the longer the bar the better backbone
alt is my
implementation you'll see like jquery's
version here their event system is
considerably slower
but they're doing a lot more they've got
a more robust event system it's for
handling elements it's not just generic
objects
and with this technique you can improve
jquery's
event uh iteration by like 18
which considering how much other stuff
they have around just removing that dot
call and dot apply
is a pretty easy tweak so if anyone digs
jquery and wants to optimize that
this would help their event system this
would help their dot each
so cool
all right i really like this this
technique
and so i you'll see a lot of this stuff
is i've taken out of lodash because
i'm not just like coming up with ideas
for optimizations i use these in my own
projects and i've
tested them i've refined them to try to
gain performance and to offset the cost
of like bug fixes or compliance
all right so avoiding binding how many
people know that you can coerce a
function to a string
and access its function source okay cool
you may also know that it's non-standard
technically
but it's like a de facto standard like
everyone kind of does it
so i found a way to avoid
the this binding if you can detect that
the function isn't
using the this keyword um and so
so so so check this out um
you
yeah so it's so i by the way this is
going to be in low dash
as well so expect it for those that are
like wow that's on stand that's not
standard
i'm kind of scared of it i in another
slide i show you how to do a feature
detection for it so you can get this
benefit
if it exists and you can drop it if it
doesn't
but the the the gist is and this is me
showing like a generic event system that
you could patch
so you could do this with jquery's event
system for example
um or backbones event system and usually
when you're registering
an event listener you you might pass in
some meta that metadata so like right
now i'm passing in like the function and
it's context
but what i'm doing is i'm testing to see
if the function uh
is using this reference and if it's not
then i'm not going to do a binding
to it and so that will that will speed
up the iteration there because it's not
just doing
this implicit this binding if you're not
using this this also allows you to say
to your devs that if they do care about
performance
that you can you can actually enforce a
different coding pattern for them and
say all right well then just do where
that equals this which is you know gross
some people hate it but
if you need it your system will now
allow for it and actually have optimus
optimizations for it kind of backed into
it
so that's that's this technique i'm
using
function.prototype.2 string because this
avoids issues if the function has a
custom to string
so like i've seen charting libraries do
that
to their instances and objects and
functions and so this way that even
avoids that
gotcha there what this will do is this
may have false positives if you have a
comment
that has dot this but in that case
the worst case scenario is that it's
treated like every every other function
and wrapped or bound so just if you know
that this could be a pattern for you to
increase performance
so what i'm doing is i'm adding this to
my iteration sugar in low dash so if you
pass this binding but your callback
isn't using it it's not going to
actually do the bind so it's going to
hit the fast path because i showed you
that that slow path is considerably
slower
for me because i do the create callback
technique
all right so here's the feature test um
for example that one up there
so i do an assignment i test to see if i
can find the this value
if i can then i return the value else
it'll be false
then you could do something similar this
was just a cheap way to do this what
i've done
in lowdash is to use the the running
context method because that's the method
that wraps everything
so it's it's a very big function body
and this allows me to detect
issues with mobile browsers that may
truncate function
string function body strings and so i
referenced this like way down there in
the bottom so if they can catch it then
i know it's it's probably safe to use
all right let's see this is me actually
showing the inside
of the listener so before i showed uh
how to register it and this is
an implementation of it using that that
information now now that i know that
i can conditionally if there is a
context
call it if not do a straight function
call and that is how you get your
performance now this is kind of like
the uh the backbones implementation
where they they do a switch statement
on on number of arguments i just did
up to one but you they do it like up to
three you may
do four it minifies to
almost nothing so if if you're totally
grossed out about that just say it's for
perf
and uh and move on um
yeah you know um okay
all right so um the the next
technique i have is reduce your searches
so a lot of people when you they have um
a lot a large array or a group of arrays
they want to do operations like
without or union or unique
on their arrays but that's doing a lot
of linear searches index sub values
going
through the collection every time and
that's very very slow
and to fix that you may think well i'll
just use an object cache
so if the if the value in this case
um turns the value into a property name
and they set
its uh result to true so then if it does
exist
as a property then they know it's there
and they can they can continue on their
way they've found the property or the
value
but there's there's a couple of problems
with that it conflates things that look
like identical at string so like the
number string
or the number two and the string two um
look the same and so if you're doing
something that is like a unique
operation
it's going to treat them as equal when
they are not um or even a function that
cores
to the for some reason course to a
number it would
with two string would do it um so that
that approach
doesn't work well for um
generic use now if that is your only use
case then maybe
maybe you could do it but this is how
you could tweak that so here's the first
one where it's index of
and you'll also see that i've got a
little bit of something up here
but i'll talk about that later
and then the the tweak is what i've done
is i've uh in this example
created a cache of that value and then i
just look to see
if it's contained in that cache
or if it's not contained in this case
now i'm going to go into actually
showing you how i create the object
cache for that so this what the idea is
is instead of doing a long linear search
you're breaking that massive array
into smaller buckets so you're taking
all of the
the in my previous example of
two like values so all of your number
twos and string twos
and sticking them into a smaller array
so you have less
of an array to search so that should be
faster and it is it's considerably
faster
and so now here's just the uh the the
small code that shows you
an implementation of this what i do is i
detect if the array is large and what is
large
it's an arbitrary number that i've
created based on research so in my case
my implementation
uh the large array size was
at one time 200 so anything over 200 got
this optimization
now it's reduced to 75 so now any array
over 75 gets this optimization
but what it is is it's the the point at
which
your cost for doing this uh actually
gives you a perf win because you're
having to sit there and create an object
and populate it with properties and
if you if your array is four items long
then it's not going to be a big
not going to be a win so what this is
doing is i'm doing a prefix
here for the value to avoid issues with
object
properties on objects prototypes so
tostring has own property
it also avoids issues with the magic
proto property double underscore proto
double underscore
and that is the implementation there i
basically push the values into their
smaller buckets
in in this cache and then in this
function here
i check to see if it is in that smaller
array
so instead of doing let's say 200 uh a
search over 200 items it's doing a
search over four
so it makes it faster
now this is me uh zooming into
that chunk right there that that is
what's actually creating
the cache but it was pretty pretty clear
before
so there's an alternative technique that
you can do that takes it
another step further and this is what
i'm doing in the next version of lodash
and what this is is instead of creating
a bunch of smaller arrays
what it's it's doing a hybrid approach
of that the first naive approach which
was
to do object properties and it's also
doing arrays
so object properties for things like
boolean values
false and true null
undefined and i only do those lookups
if i'm looking for a value that is
one of those so it's not going to get a
false positive like with the the number
two and the string
two and then i have an object cache
for anything else that's an object so
then they'll get the
their own arrays there
and this is just me creating that cache
again
still you know if it's an object it's
getting pushed into the smaller array
if it's one of the other primitive
values it's being set to trip
so that's the hybrid of the naive
approach and the the
smaller bucket approach and this gets
considerable ones this was this allowed
me to remove
to reduce the size of my large array
limit from 200 down to 75 so that means
more
arrays are impacted and more you get
better performance out of it because
your optimization kicks in earlier
cool all right another another technique
is
um by the way that that optimization can
be used in underscore
um and possibly jquery
another thing you can do here is uh
coerce values with care
a lot of times devs will get in the
habit of doing slice.call arguments
all the time just whether they need to
or not they're sliced.calling arguments
and in many cases you don't have to
arguments are an array-like object if
you're about to iterate over
arguments you don't have to convert them
to an array you can just iterate over
them straight up
um and many times you can avoid slicing
them if you just
if you are going to iterate over them
just set your i index or your
your index value uh to one or something
so you don't have to slice
them there's an example uh here where
i've done that
where instead of instead of slicing your
arguments and doing an index search
actually i missed a value there but use
your imagination there's a value there
argument instead of that i'm leveraging
the the from
index of index of so index of an array
index of in this case the library index
of
allows you to set a from index where you
start your linear search from
so it doesn't always have to start from
zero it can start forward so you don't
have to slice things there
you can also avoid things like concat
so let's see
i have a typo which is lame
but i'll jump down to this example over
here
um instead of flattening a lot of times
devs will include a lib to flatten
arrays and you don't have to you can use
native concat
concat flattens arrays so in this case i
have a variable reference to concat i
also have a variable reference to slice
so if you see slice up there without
anything that's me
storing their slice equals
array.prototype.slice
um and instead you can use um
concat to flatten your arrays and you
don't have to pass
it an array as it's this arg so i've
seen many libs do this where they're
just creating garbage
like extra unneeded arrays there and you
can tidy that up
the array.prototype itself is an array
so you can use that
as the this as the this value there
which is what i do
in uh lodash2 and i believe it's been
added to underscore
but this that pattern there is from uh
jquery so if you're a jquery fan you can
go and patch that up
and i'm sure you could find it in all
the other libs too they all kind of
do similar things there and you can you
can tighten up
their obj their dead object creation
and then the bottom one is avoiding
concat when it's not needed so in this
case
they were doing food.concat slice
arrays slash arguments and you can
you can avoid that and do like push
dot apply and push because push accepts
more than just one argument
to push i don't know if many of how many
people knew that you could push more
than
one argument okay cool well you can and
so you can leverage that applied there
and push all of your arguments onto the
array without having to do concat and
creating all these intermediate arrays
so try that instead and that's me again
having a reference to
array.prototype.push assigned to a
variable push
okay sugar in moderation
how many people use jquery's chaining
syntax
not jquery's underscores chaining syntax
okay
a few if you're using a lib that's
optimized for the generic use
you need to be aware that the chaining
syntax the non-common syntax has a
performance penalty so if you have an
animation framework or a tight loop
try pulling it back to the api that is
is
optimized for that library
before you even have to roll it back to
like for loops or go crazy
other optimizations um and in this case
i've shown the the difference between
the two there
you've got the um the chain version
versus the generic version and there's a
trade-off there one is pretty
and in the chaining api is very pretty
but the other one is actually how it was
designed
to be used uh from its core so it's
faster
this way keep in mind the differences
underscore and lodash are optimized for
their generic use but mood tools and
anything that operates on a prototype so
that even means jquery are optimized for
the chaining syntax so be aware of the
libs you're using
be aware of that in your own code too
like if you're doing something that's a
moderately performance intensive or
could be make sure you're using the api
that's appropriate for
your uh your use all right
next i wanted to say is
with the chaining syntax if you do have
a chaining syntax there's an
optimization opportunity there
and that is deferred evaluation so just
a week or two ago
i saw a library come out that was called
lazy.js which was boasting better
performance than lodash haha
it caught my attention um
because because yeah i'm pretty
competitive in that
in that space um and
now normal usage normal usage you could
see
i i beat them i beat i beat underscore
two underscores the little blue
i'm the big blue um but
but but as the as the complexity of the
chain functions increases
this one starts to win and win by a
considerable amount
and that's because uh what they're doing
is instead of doing
200 iterations for map and then doing
200 iterations for filter and then doing
some other things in their collections
so iteration iteration iteration and
then at the end
only getting the the last five values
lazy evaluation at that time doesn't
execute that at all it adds it to a
queue
and then whenever you call to array or
in this case like if you're familiar
with the
underscore loadout chaining syntax the
value command or the value method
that's when it flattens that down and
instead of it being 200 or 400 or 600
iterations
since you're only needing five values at
the end because you're saying like take
the last five values
it only does five iterations and so that
gives you
you know massive performance wins so as
your chaining gets longer
you get better wins now
uh i'm experimenting with adding support
for this because i liked it so much and
i like the the performance opportunity
my chaining syntax is usually a perf hit
because it's
like i said low dash and underscore are
optimized for
um the generic use but i can back this
in
oops
hey hey matt um no it's cool
let's see boop
someone's birthday all right
yeah all right and
that's it questions
so general use cases um the use case
i've seen promoted
throughout like documentation or through
tutorials
so in my case i know that that most most
devs aren't passing that this value
there so i know that the common case is
not to do that
it's being familiar with your own lib
being familiar especially if you're the
lib author
being familiar with how you want your
devs to use that api and how you're
promoting it through your
your evangelism and then you know what
the the common case would be so you can
optimize for it
what going back to the themes again
where i said optimize for the common
case
uh jquery has an implicit this binding
in its event system because if you know
if you're doing
each or whatever you'll see this equals
is is the element that's currently being
iterated over or something
and that was baked in from the beginning
so it's hard to kind of back in perf
there because they're always doing dot
collar dot apply
um but if you want that 18 boost
what you can do is do that uh that
function sniff inference where you can
detect if the this binding is there and
and toggle it but you wouldn't have to
go to that length if
at the beginning you said oh okay maybe
not all going to use this or maybe this
will become
an anti-pattern or whatever and they
could instead
have have put that property on the event
object that they're already passing down
and so that would have avoided a dot
call to begin with so when you're doing
like your event system you could think
oh maybe i don't need an implicit this i
could just
add a property to the event object that
i'm passing to every
callback anyways and so just kind of
keep these things in your
your head as you're developing um your
libraries
or your own code bases so yeah cool
um so the question was have you looked
at any of these
anti-patterns in coffeescript uh i
don't use coffeescript so no i i haven't
um
what's nice about copyscript is it just
com is boils down to basic
javascript um and in many cases
its sugar boils down to for loops so
that's right up my alley like it doesn't
defer to native methods it turns it into
for loops and it has small
utility functions um which are very nice
um
also i'll be positive about coffeescript
and say i like its class abstraction
but yeah uh yes
i need to do more research there
um but i do have a big function on mine
i only do it once though for the future
detect
but so far it's given perf gains in the
test that i've i've done
you could always do more research dig
into it i'm going to try it i'm going to
give it a shot because i think it's
relatively safe and stable especially
for modern builds
so what i'm doing is i'm opting that
into just so just
ie9 up and modern modern
browsers will do this not old browsers
because that just means
bugs just yeah and bugs get big
well the idea is that i'm doing that
load that work outside the loop
so it's done once outside the loop
instead of like every time inside the
loop so it's again hoisting things out
of your loop
cool yes
yeah good good good good question so the
the the question
was um in create callback which was the
the code i
have up here
and i'm going to get to it i can't speak
and
move at the same time okay um
the question was in create callback why
not use function.prototype.bind instead
of rapping
and that's because many times
in in most browser implementations
function.prototype.bind is actually
slower
especially like in v8 it's considerably
and in lowdash actually is aware of this
and will not use
bind in v8 i do an inference for its
engine
which is really cool because i can
detect the js engine
um through a little inference um but uh
even in browsers where it's relatively
fast or faster than
than a fully spec compliant bind
alternative
bind is still slower than just wrapping
it so i thought i was going to get a
perf boost there too and i was really
surprised that it didn't
it didn't do it or else i would have
yeah i've done that what's up yes
um i i for the the purpose of this
this demonstration i kind of wanted it
really simple to just do word boundary
this word boundary
you can experiment with with other
variations of it
if you see that as a problem i don't
know if i'm going to see a lot of people
having that issue but if it is and if
it's a concern i would i'd still kept it
simple that way it's just a quick regex
that just
finds it or fails fast um but yeah you
could you could modify the regex
to detect uh comments i don't know if i
repeated the question but it was
could you modify the this regex to look
for comments instead
uh another any other questions
yes
yeah so um i had a slide uh here that i
removed which was
um how to better uh
how to have create call be better
detected for inlining
because some engines have an issue with
that function call out there
and so what you would do is do a check
for
if this is undefined don't do the
function call at all and just have it
do the have it do they have it be the
callbacks so a ternary operation
of that um engines are tricky
engines under the hood are they're doing
all kinds of crazy stuff
to just get the result and get it fast
and jit and what what
gets optimized and what doesn't this is
why i said it's a balance
of how how deep you want to go into it
and i think this is a decent trade-off
because
it's not just it's it's it's giving me
win on top of win here because
it's optimizing for the common case and
allowing me to extend functionality
for each to and other iteration methods
to have like the callback shorthand
sugar
of the property access or
partial object filtering
so that's that's what i dig a side note
is
since we're talking about engines is
that i've noticed that minified code
will have different performance profiles
than your non-minified code
potentially in different engines so if
you're developing a project
and you have a performance critical
thing like an animation lib or something
you want to test your minified code in
your benchmarks as well as your
non-minified
i found issues with uglify.js and
closure compiler
where they because of their patterns
they're using when they minify
de-optimize like safari and mobile
safari so again really
really good to test that and
what i've done is in lodash i have a
minification system where i
i run all these minifiers and then get
the smallest build but then i also go
back and i fix
the the patterns that the minifiers are
doing that slow
down the engine so i avoid the d ops but
it's something to do like if you're if
you don't have a perf suite
for your library you should create one
and if you have a favorite library
and they don't have a perf suite you
should add one and a perfect lib to do
that is benchmark.js and you can look at
lodash's implementation
for example of a perfect blip any other
questions
yes
no um uh without you just ha each engine
is different each engine has its own
rules
with that minification issue what was
happening was i believe what was
happening
was that the minified code was not
getting in line for some reason
it was passing some threshold of byte
code or whatever
and it was missing the inlining
opportunity there and so it was
it was reducing its performance by 30
percent
um so it was pretty pretty glaring but
as to what
gets uh inlined and what doesn't the the
general rule is to keep your functions
small
and then they have a better chance of
being inlined
and that that kind of goes at odds with
my other point which is reduce
abstraction
because you're going to have all these
function calls so i would say
profile and then make your decision
don't just
take my word for it that's why i also
didn't include a lot of performance
charts because all you'd see is these
bars with them being really big over
here and really small over there
and i want you to not take my word for
it to actually go out and use jsperf and
other benchmarks and
and verify that you get these wins like
don't
don't um if you do a pull request
back it up with a performance benchmark
so you can say hey this actually does
this and if it doesn't
then it's still good you've learned
something you you know not to do it in
that that's a certain situation
you